bien j'ai toujours avec anne parillaud
des soins on voir quel type de mec vous
êtes jean michel jarre on va faire une
interview vérif est-ce que vous avez
déjà appliqué une fille à un copain
piqué peut-être pas si y'a pus ya pu y
avoir une passation de pouvoir
jean pierre raffarin c'est bien ce qu'on
a à faire on bat accusés ne fait on va
noter ceux qui tombent vraiment je suis
là il tombe jusqu'à la passation de
pouvoir jean pierre raffarin bravo
laurent et je voulais déjà trompé votre
copine alors qu'elle était enceinte
2 non je veux tenter pourquoi il a
jamais embrassé personne jean-pierre à
sa femme mais j'ai envie de copines
enceintes
ouais donc je n'ai pas pu et voilà donc
d'accord vous ai déjà proposé le mariage
et une fille en sachant que vous le
feriez pas non vous avez déjà révélé que
les seins d'une fille était faux
révélé à qui ad'autres j'ai bien une
idée mais ça va pas lui père
dix sept ans que vous êtes déjà barré
chez une fille à wangen se réveille à
jamie on dit la vérité at it et je me
réveille bon non je crois pas non
essayez déjà jean pierre raffarin
celui-là on peut nourrir on pouvait s de
poids bien voilà il est déjà rappelé une
ex juste pour vérifier qu'elle voulait
encore couché avec de menois gbagbo
n'honore baba il le fait mais non pas du
tout comme ça moi et tout ça finalement
celle qui me fait penser non situation
est-ce que tu as menti parlant c'est une
interview tu as toujours une positive
attitude quand même mois jean michel
jarre
shalom